.
Es geschieht dort,
wo es niemand erwartet.
Dann, wenn niemand damit rechnet.
Aus Gründen, die niemand kennt.
Und wer doch etwas weiss,
der schweigt.
Es sind ungelöste Mordfälle,
die die Angehörigen
in Schmerz und Trauer stürzen
und die Ermittler
ratlos zurücklassen.
Wir hatten von Anfang bis Schluss
praktisch keine Spuren,
praktisch keine Ermittlungsansätze.
(Frau) Am liebsten
würdest du weinen und schreien.
Aber das bringt nichts.
Du musst stark bleiben und hoffen,
dass man ihn finden.
Das war eine Hinrichtung.
Aber der Grund, das Motiv
war schon damals unklar.
Man fand
keine gemeinsame Verbindung.
Es ist
ein riesiges, ungelöstes Rätsel,
warum diese Menschen
sterben mussten.
Mit Untertiteln von SWISS TXT
* Beklemmende Klänge *
Wieso musste Patricia Wilhelm
am 27. Februar 2004 sterben?
Wer ist die Person, die zweimal -
am 15. Dezember 2010
und am genau gleichen Tag,
fünf Jahre später -
seine DNA
am Tatort zweier Morde hinterliess?
Wer brachte am 6. Juni 1976
in Seewen fünf Menschen um?
Es ist seit jeher
das Schweigen des Wissenden,
das dem Ermittler
langsam jede Hoffnung raubt.
(Fernsehsprecher) 7. Juni 1976:
Die "Tagesschau" meldet
eines der grössten Verbrechen
der Schweizer Kriminalgeschichte.
Am Morgen des 6. Juni 1976
wollte die Tochter des Besitzers
dieses Wochenendhauses
ihre Eltern besuchen.
Sie fand Patronenhülsen und Blut-
spuren und alarmierte die Polizei.
Den eintreffenden Beamten
bot sich ein Bild des Grauens.
Sie standen vor fünf blutüber-
strömten Leichen älterer Menschen.
Die Gerichtsreporterin
Christine Brand
befasste sich in ihrer Arbeit mit
zahlreichen ungelösten Mordfällen.
Der Mordfall Seewen ist eines der
grössten Verbrechen in der Schweiz.
Und es ist der grösste Fall,
der noch nicht geklärt wurde.
Das ist das,
was die Schweiz erschreckt hat.
Die heile Welt,
die man eigentlich hatte
oder hat in der Schweiz,
mit einer
normalen Verbrechenslage ...
Und dann gibt es einen solchen
Schlag, so ein massloses Delikt.
Das war das Erschreckendste:
Eine heile Welt ging kaputt.
Das gibt es auch in der Schweiz,
nicht nur Amerika.
Mein Name ist Jäggi Max.
Ich war damals 40-jährig,
als das Ganze losging.
Als Sachbearbeiter hatte ich
an diesem Pfingstwochenende Pikett.
Am Sonntagmittag
erhielt ich das Telefon.
Ich wurde informiert,
dass es einen Vorfall gab in Seewen.
Dann rückte ich aus.
46 Jahre nach diesem Fünffachmord
besucht Jäggi den Tatort.
Noch immer nagt an ihm, dass er
den Fall nie ganz lösen konnte.
Fast ein halbes Jahrhundert
nach dem Blutbad von Seewen
bleiben Fragen offen.
Fünf Menschen
starben an jenem Pfingstsamstag.
Die Tochter des Ehepaares
hatte die Leichen entdeckt.
Als Jäggi und seine Leute eintrafen,
wurde ihnen das Ausmass
erst richtig bewusst.
Auf den Gehplatten rund ums das Haus
hatte es rote Flecken.
Edith dachte,
das sei von den Kirschen.
Aber die Kirschen
waren noch gar nicht reif.
Bei der Spurensicherung
stellte man fest, dass es Blut war.
Die beiden Söhne Westhäuser
lagen in einem Raum,
Frau Westhäuser und Herr Siegrist,
auch Geschwister,
in einem anderen Raum.
Frau Siegrist war eingewickelt
im Teppich auf der Veranda.
Das gabt mir schon
ein komisches Gefühl.
Warum war das so?
Fünf erwachsene Menschen - erschossen
an einem Waldrand bei Seewen.
Ein Verbrechen von noch nie
dagewesenem Ausmass in der Schweiz.
Im Gasthof Sonne
errichtete die Kripo Solothurn kurz
nach der Tat einen Kommandoposten.
20 Beamte gehen hier täglich
ihrer verschwiegenen Tätigkeit nach.
Man sieht sie kommen und gehen,
von ihrer Arbeit erfährt man nichts.
Erfolge und Misserfolge im Fortgang
ihrer Ermittlungstätigkeit
werden der Öffentlichkeit
bis zur endgültigen Aufklärung
des Verbrechens vorenthalten.
Ein erster Befund des
Gerichtsmediziners lautete dahin,
dass mindestens vier
der fünf Personen
im Freien erschossen wurden.
Alle Leichen weisen Kopfschüsse auf.
Bis zum heutigen Tag weiss niemand,
warum das Ehepaar
Elsa und Eugen Siegrist,
Eugens Schwester
Anna Westhäuser-Siegrist,
sowie deren Söhne Emanuel
und Max Westhäuser sterben mussten.
Die dunklen Seiten des Täters
oder auch der Opfer
sind schwierig zu ermitteln.
Die Polizei verfolgte in den Wochen
und Monaten danach jede Spur,
ging über 9'000 Hinweisen nach -
vergeblich.
Die Tat blieb ungeklärt,
obwohl die Polizei
einen grösseren Aufwand betrieb
als bei jedem Verbrechen zuvor.
Es schien keine Zeugen zu geben.
Man kann sagen,
dass dieser Fall für niemanden
gewöhnliche Polizeiarbeit ist.
Willkommen waren wir nicht
bei der Bevölkerung,
aber das ist egal,
das spielt keine Rolle.
Es war natürlich
aussergewöhnlich für sie,
dass die Polizei
jeden Tag im Dorf ist.
Naja.
(Fernsehsprecher) Seit dem 6. Juni
sind die wenigen Spuren gesichert.
Die Kripo hat nicht nur die Kugeln
ins ballistische Labor geschickt,
man hat sogar das ganze Ferienhaus
der Opfer abtransportiert.
Hunderte von Ermittlungs-
und Fahndungsrapporten
stapeln sich
im Kommandoposten von Seewen.
Dies ist eine Patrone,
wie sie im Tötungsdelikt Seewen
verwendet wurde.
Es ist ein Kaliber .38 Special.
Man wusste bald,
dass es ein Repetiergewehr
gewesen sein musste,
wie man es im Film sieht.
Es musst
eine Winchester-Waffe gewesen sein.
Doch wer besass
zu dieser Zeit eine Winchester?
Nur über die Antwort auf diese Frage
würde die Polizei den Täter finden.
Man orientierte alle
Polizeikommandos mit dem Auftrag,
mit den Waffenhändlern in
den jeweiligen Kantonen abzuklären,
wer eine solche Waffe gekauft hat.
Das passierte dann auch so.
Schlussendlich
kamen 1'300 Gewehre infrage.
Da es sich um einen Mord an mehreren
Familienmitgliedern handelte,
suchte die Polizei zu Beginn
im nächsten Umfeld der Opfer.
Robert Siegrist,
der Sohn von Elsa und Eugen Siegrist,
wurde verdächtigt und verhaftet.
Das war der Pfingstsonntag 1976,
als ich und meine damaligen Freundin
und jetzigen Frau verhaftet wurde.
Uns wurde nicht gesagt,
um was es ging.
Polizeibeamte in Zivil
waren plötzlich da.
Sie drangen ins Elternhaus
meiner Freundin ein.
Sie packten uns,
hielten uns ihre Waffen vor,
wir mussten die Hände hochheben.
Wir wurden abgeführt
nach Liestal auf den Polizeiposten,
wo wir intensiv verhört wurden.
Erst nach Stunden erfuhren wir -
bez. erfuhr ich,
denn wir wurden getrennt verhört -,
worum es ging.
Was passierte,
war schon sehr schlimm
und wurde mir
sehr schonungslos mitgeteilt.
Anschliessend
wurde ich noch verdächtigt,
dass ich derjenige sein könnte,
der es getan hat.
Das ist ein logischer Schritt.
Praktisch bei jedem Fall werden
zuerst die Angehörigen befragt:
Wie? Wo? Wann?
Und man klärt das Alibi ab.
Sie können ruhig sagen,
wo sie waren.
Wenn nichts dahinter ist,
können sie es ja sagen.
Robert Siegrist, hier rechts neben
seinem getöteten Cousin Emanuel,
stand also plötzlich unter Verdacht,
seine Eltern und Verwandten
getötet zu haben.
Das hat er nicht goutiert.
Er war von Anfang an
gegen die Untersuchungsbehörden
und gegen die Polizei.
Der Verdacht erhärtete sich nicht,
Robert Siegrist wurde freigelassen.
Und noch immer
fehlte das Motiv für die Tat.
Es ist sehr schwierig zu sagen,
was es war.
Niemand kennt das Motiv.
Für mich
ist es klar ein Familienmord,
eine ganze Familie wurde
ausgelöscht, ein Mehrfachmord.
Für mich ist es kein Amoklauf.
Denn Amokläufer suchen kein
einsames Häuschen am Waldrand auf.
Ein Amokläufer
hat meistens ein Ziel im Kopf
mit möglichst vielen Menschen.
Ich gehe davon aus, dass der Täter
eine Beziehung zu den Opfern hatte,
ein persönliches Motiv hatte,
diese Menschen umzubringen.
Aber was genau das Motiv war,
wurde nie geklärt.
Ich möchte den Rapport eröffnen.
1976 war eine andere Zeit. Die
Polizisten mussten anders ermitteln.
Heute
hätte man eine DNA-Spur gefunden.
Wenn die Asservate
aufbewahrt worden wären,
z.B. ein Pullover eines Opfers
oder Blut auf einer Decke,
hätte man dies im Nachhinein
auf DNA untersuchen können.
Etwas, das zum Tatzeitpunkt - also
vor 1990 - noch keine Spur war,
hätte plötzlich als Spurenmaterial
dienen können,
weil wir es jetzt auswerten können.
Die Schweiz hat bei Tötungsdelikten
eine sehr hohe Aufklärungsrate.
Neun von zehn Fällen werden gelöst.
Und doch gibt es immer wieder solche,
die unlösbar scheinen.
In Zürich ereignete sich
am 15. Dezember 2010 ein Mordfall,
den die Polizei bis heute
nicht aufklären konnte.
Dabei schien der Täter
mit den Behörden
ein makabres Spiel zu spielen.
Rein zufällig
begleitete an jenem Abend
ein Team des Schweizer Fernsehens SRF
den Staatsanwalt Matthias Stammbach.
(Fernsehsprecher)
Zürich Seefeld, Mitte Dezember.
Das ruhige Wohnquartier
ist Schauplatz
eines brutalen Verbrechens geworden.
Die Polizei hat bereits eine
mobile Einsatzzentrale aufgestellt.
Matthias Stammbach wurde als dienst-
habender Staatsanwalt aufgeboten.
15. Dezember 2010:
Ich war zu Hause
am frühen Abend - etwa nach 18 Uhr.
Dann erhielt ich ein Telefon.
Mir wurde gesagt, dass man
von einem Tötungsdelikt ausgehe
im Zürcher Seefeld.
Dann macht man sich auf.
Staatsanwaltschaft,
Polizeibeamte, Rechtsmedizin.
Im Moment
tappen noch alle im Dunkeln.
Jetzt geht es darum, alle auf
den gleichen Wissensstand zu bringen.
Wir haben
eine tote Frau aufgefunden.
Die Tatwaffe war wohl ein Messer.
Fünf Jahre lang hatte ich kein
einziges vollendetes Tötungsdelikt.
Seefeld war
das erste vollendete Tötungsdelikt.
Das zeigt, dass es
selten und nicht alltäglich ist.
Man ist natürlich nervös,
angespannt, voller Adrenalin.
Man ist voll konzentriert.
Das Opfer: eine Psychotherapeutin.
Entdeckt hatte sie ein Patient,
der bei ihr
einen Termin vereinbart hatte.
An der Haustür?- Nein,
hier an der Wohnungstür, draussen.
Er sei hineingekommen,
es sei dunkel gewesen.
Er habe gewartet
und habe dann angerufen.
Dann habe es geklingelt
und er sei hineingegangen.
* Beklemmende Klänge *
Die vier Kameras an der
Wildbachstrasse 46 waren Attrappen.
Wäre schön gewesen.
Die Fensterschau machten
die zwei stationierten Kollegen.
Die iPhone-Suche wurde eingeleitet.
Bez. der Tatwaffe
kann man noch etwas machen.
Wenn er die wegschmeisst und sie
irgendwo unter einem Auto ist ...
Der Hund ist schon durch.
- Ja, ich weiss.
Wir nehmen es in die Pendenzen auf:
morgen früh
eine erneute Nahbereichsfahndung.
Obwohl der Täter
Spuren hinterlassen hatte,
obwohl die Polizei schnell vor Ort
war und akribisch arbeitete,
obwohl im Anschluss
erstmals in der Schweiz
Massen-DNA-Tests durchgeführt wurden,
gelang es nicht,
den Täter zu ermitteln.
Es gab keine entscheidenden Hinweise,
keine Zeugen.
* Traurige Klänge *
Blanche Woiton weiss,
wie es sich anfühlt,
Angehörige in einem
ungeklärten Mordfall zu verlieren.
Die grosse Leidenschaft
der französisch-schweizerischen
Doppelbürgerin sind Trabrennen.
Sie wurde ihr von Gerda K.
und Georges S. weitergegeben.
Die beiden waren
zwar keine leiblichen Verwandte,
für Blanche aber
waren sie wie Grosseltern.
Ich konnte einfach auf sie zählen.
Wenn ich ein Problem hatte,
konnte ich sie immer anrufen.
Sie waren immer für mich da.
Sie sind herzliche Menschen.
Blanche Woiton verbrachte
die ersten zehn Jahre ihres Lebens
auf Georges' und Gerdas Pferdegestüt
im Elsass.
Ein paar Jahre später,
als Georges und Gerda
wieder in der Schweiz lebten,
wurden sie Opfer
eines rätselhaften Mordes.
Anzeichen dafür
hatte es keine gegeben.
Jeden Dienstag
haben wir normalerweise telefoniert.
Plötzlich haben wir
nichts mehr gehört.
Ich rief sie an, meine Mutter auch.
Normalerweise
war sie durchgehend erreichbar.
Wenn Georges oder sonst jemand
sie brauchte, war sie da.
Dann haben wir nichts mehr gehört
und plötzlich stand in der Zeitung,
dass es einen Mord gegeben hatte.
Das pensionierte Ehepaar wurde
in Laupen im Kanton Bern ermordet.
Wieder war es kurz vor Weihnachten,
wieder fehlte ein Motiv.
Es war für uns ein Untergang.
Das haben wir nicht erwartet.
Es war heftig und niemand
konnte uns Antworten geben.
Dass der Mord auf den Tag genau
fünf Jahre nach dem Mord
im Zürcher Seefeld geschah,
schien reiner Zufall.
Der Fallanalytiker Hans-Peter Meister
war damals bei diesem Verbrechen
vor Ort im Einsatz.
Sieben Jahre danach
kehrt er an den Tatort zurück,
eine alte Käserei,
in der die Mordopfer wohnten.
* Beklemmende Klänge *
Der heutige Besitzer hat Meister
den Zutritt ins Gebäude erlaubt.
Im Wohnraum erinnert heute nichts
mehr an die damaligen Vorkommnisse.
Ich versuche mich zurechtzufinden.
Das Mobiliar hat sich verändert.
Genau hier
wurden Georges S. und Gerda K.
am 15. Dezember 2015 mutmasslich
mit einem Beil erschlagen.
Die Küche ist hier.
Wenn es noch die gleiche Küche ist,
waren sie wohl etwa hier
bereit fürs Abendessen.
* Beklemmende Klänge *
Es ist seltsam.
Es ist ein komisches Gefühl
zu wissen, was hier passiert ist
oder wie es vorher war.
Für die, die es nicht wissen,
spielt es keine Rolle.
Wenn man die Deko anschaut ...
Klar, es ist sieben Jahre her,
aber man spürt es trotzdem noch.
Es ist der 13. Dezember.
In zwei Tagen sind es acht Jahre.
Ja.
Das mutet seltsam an.
Vom Tatort zum Partykeller.
Der Fall konnte nicht gelöst werden.
Keine Hinweise, keine Zeugenaussagen.
Die Polizei musste sich
mit den vielen, scheinbar
unbrauchbaren Spuren begnügen,
die sie am Tatort
sichergestellt hatte.
Doch dann machten die Ermittler
eine überraschende Entdeckung:
Bei der DNA-Analyse im Labor
fanden sie eine Übereinstimmung
mit der DNA aus einem früheren Fall.
Nicht aus irgendeinem Fall,
sondern aus jenem im Zürcher Seefeld,
der sich fünf Jahre
vor diesem hier ereignet hatte.
Das konnte nichts anderes heissen,
als dass es der gleiche Täter war:
Ich bekam die Mitteilung,
dass es einen Spur-Spur-Hit gab.
Ich wurde sehr nervös.
Bern-Laupen, genau.
* Beklemmende Klänge *
Es geht um zwei Tötungsdelikte,
die auf den ersten Blick gar
nichts miteinander zu tun haben,
anderer Ort, anderes Milieu.
In Zürich wurde eine Therapeutin
in ihrer Praxis umgebracht,
im Berner Seeland ein älteres
Ehepaar bei sich zu Hause.
Die Besonderheit ist:
Man hat an beiden Tatorten
die gleiche DNA-Spur gefunden,
an einem Ort, der beweist,
dass die DNA dem Täter gehören muss.
Sonst wäre niemand
auf die Idee gekommen,
dass die zwei Fälle miteinander
etwas zu tun haben.
Dass sie am selben Tag passierten,
kann ein Zufall sein.
Ohne DNA-Spur haben wir im Prinzip
zwei unterschiedliche Tötungsdelikte
an verschiedenen Orten.
Welches Geheimnis bergen dieses Haus
im ländlichen Laupen in Bern
und diese Praxis im Zürcher Seefeld?
Wer schweigt, obwohl er mehr weiss?
Mich fasziniert an dem Fall,
dass man keine Erklärung
und Verbindung findet.
Es muss aber eine geben,
aber man findet sie einfach nicht.
Was ist das Motiv?
Oder umgekehrt betrachtet:
Welche Motiv sind es nicht?
Ein sexuelles Motiv?
Das wüssten wir, das wäre bekannt.
Ein finanzielles Motiv?
Ein konkretes Beispiel:
Ich mache Raubüberfälle oder
Einbrüche, weil ich Geld möchte.
Dann ist die Praxis
in einer 1-1/2-Zimmerwohnung
in einem Mehrfamilienhaus
kein lohnenswertes Objekt.
Im Keller einer alten Käserei
erwarte ich keine 200'000 Fr.
Von aussen sieht es nicht
danach aus, dass hier jemand wohnt,
der Geld auf der Seite hat.
Dann bleibt noch
ein Beziehungsdelikt.
Gibt es zwischen den Opfern
und dem Täter Konfliktfelder,
die dazu geführt haben?
In erster Linie haben
die Ermittlungen nichts ergeben.
Wenn wir - statistisch gesehen -
95 % der Beziehungsdelikte
aufklären,
war das hier
zu 95 % auch kein Beziehungsdelikt.
Es ist also ein Fall ohne Motiv,
das Warum.
Zweimal hatte der Mörder am
15. Dezember getötet, 2010 und 2015.
Mit ungutem Gefühl erwarteten
Ermittler in der ganzen Schweiz
den 15. Dezember 2020.
Doch nichts geschah.
Was bleibt, ist die unheimliche
Erkenntnis eines jeden Ermittlers:
Das Wissen,
dass ein Mensch da draussen ist,
der für drei Tötungsdelikte
verantwortlich gemacht wird,
ist bei mir einmalig.
Es gibt auch
wenige Staatsanwält/-innen,
die erlebt haben, dass die Täter-
schaft nicht ermittelt werden kann.
Dass Mordfälle
nur selten ungelöst bleiben,
mag für die Ermittler ein Trost sein,
nicht aber
für die betroffenen Angehörigen.
Du fragst dich immer wieder,
v.a. am Todestag,
warum und wie das passierte.
Du kriegst keine Auskunft,
du weisst es nicht.
Ich war nicht verwandt mit ihnen,
aber sie waren
wie Grosseltern für mich.
Ich bin mit ihnen aufgewachsen.
Ich habe noch die Hoffnung,
dass sie jemanden finden,
damit man das klären kann.
Wenn es heute mit allen technischen
Möglichkeiten nicht gelingt,
Mordfälle zu klären,
wie gross oder klein
ist die Wahrscheinlichkeit,
nach 46 Jahren zu erfahren,
wer 1976 in Seewen Elsa
und Eugen Siegrist getötet hat?
Und wer am selben Tag auch
Anna Westhäuser
und ihre Söhne Max und Emanuel
kaltblütig erschoss?
Fallanalytiker Hanspeter Meister
hat sich auch
mit diesem Tötungsdelikt befasst.
Aufgrund der gesicherten Spuren vor
Ort und Aufzeichnungen aus jener Zeit
versucht er,
den Fünffachmord zu rekonstruieren.
Man sieht, dass alle Leichen
visuell versteckt wurden.
Elsa
wurde in den Teppich eingewickelt.
Das sieht man auf diesem Foto.
Sie ist nicht mehr sichtbar.
Der Täter hat die anderen vier
an den Beinen ins Haus gezogen
und die Tür geschlossen.
Bevor er ging, überdeckte er
grösseren Blutlachen mit Zeitungen.
Dann verschwand er mit dem Auto.
Konkret heisst das, wenn jetzt
jemand durchläuft, sieht er nichts.
Nach seiner Theorie
wurde zuerst Elsa Siegrist,
danach ihr Ehemann Eugen erschossen.
Dann wartete der Täter
auf seine nächsten drei Opfer.
Ich behaupte, Anna Westhäuser
bekam den ersten Schuss in den Kopf.
Die andere beiden, ihre Söhne,
standen hinter ihr.
Anna geht mit einem Kopfschuss
hier unmittelbar zu Boden.
Dieser Blutfleck blieb.
Max wird jetzt mit mehreren Schüssen
auch niedergestreckt.
In dem Moment flüchtet Emanuel, der
auch noch dort stand, in den Wald.
Davon gehe ich aufgrund
des Fundbilds und der Spuren aus.
Er rannte weg.
Der Täter verfolgt ihn
und schiesst in seine Richtung,
traf ihn aber nicht.
Hinter dem Haus haben wir ...
Emanuel rauchte Stumpen.
Vermutlich hatte er den Stumpen
hier noch im Mund.
So komisch sich das anhört,
aber er hatte effektiv ...
Hier hinten fand man den Stumpen.
Und hier erwischte ihn vermutlich
der Schuss.
Er kam zurück zum Haus,
um nachzuschauen.
Kann diese Rekonstruktion
späten Aufschluss geben?
Könnte es gar sein,
dass es der Täter gar nicht auf das
Ehepaar Siegrist abgesehen hatte,
sondern auf seine Besucher?
Hätte er sonst einen Grund gehabt,
nach dem Ehepaar
drei weitere Menschen zu töten?
Es bleiben Fragen.
Das Motiv ist unbekannt.
Man hat keine Anhaltspunkte,
worum es gegangen sein könnte.
Es sind Annahmen vorhanden,
aber das spielt hier keine Rolle.
Auf diese möchte ich
nicht weiter eingehen.
Damals blieb der Polizei
nichts anderes übrig,
als nach der Waffe und über diese
nach dem Täter zu suchen.
Das ist eine Repetierwaffe.
Ich ziele, drücke ab, lade nach,
ziele, drücke ab, lade nach.
Es gibt eine Schockstarre, aber der
Täter muss trotzdem weiterschiessen.
Ich gehe davon aus, dass der Täter
diese Waffe im Griff hatte,
er kannte diese Waffe,
konnte mit dieser schiessen.
Wo auch immer er geübt hatte.
Bald glaubte die Polizei,
eine Spur zu haben.
Diese führte zu einem nahen
Verwandten namens Adolf Siegrist.
Wir verkauften die Munition
und trugen die 100 Schuss ein.
Daraufhin kontrollierte die Polizei
unsere Bücher
und notierte die Käufer
dieser Patrone .38 Special.
Sehr viele Waffenbesitzer
hatten solche Revolver.
Von einem Gewehr
sprach noch niemand.
U.a. hatte man auch
die Adresse dieses Basler Mannes,
Herrn Siegrist gesehen.
Also der Cousin?
Der Cousin, Adolf Siegrist,
war bekannt - ein Waffennarr.
Dann fiel es mir plötzlich
wie Schuppen von den Augen.
"Verdammt", sagte ich,
"er hat diese Munition gekauft".
100 Schuss Winchester
200 grain Super Police.
Er hat die gekauft.
Sofort wurde öffentlich,
dass die Polizei
einen Verdächtigen gefasst hatte.
Der Fall schien gelöst.
Doch für Jäggi
und seine Kollegen war schnell klar:
Der Verdächtige,
ein kleiner Mann von 1,5 m Grösse,
konnte die fünf Menschen
unmöglich alleine überwältigt
und die Toten
in der Hütte versteckt haben.
Es müssten Mittäter oder Mithelfer
dabei gewesen sein.
Die Kraft,
um fünf Personen zu verstecken,
hätte er nicht gehabt.
20 Jahre lang ermittelte die Polizei
auf der Suche nach einem Motiv
in alle Richtungen.
Ging es um Geld?
Um aussereheliche Affären, aus denen
ein Sohn hervorgegangen sein soll?
Oder doch
um eine Abrechnung im Nazimilieu,
zu dem Anna Westhäuser
Kontakte gepflegt haben soll?
Doch dann: ein Durchbruch.
Das ist diese Waffe.
Stolz präsentierte Max Jäggi 1996
die Tatwaffe.
In einer Wohnung in Olten
wurde sie bei der Renovation
der Küche gefunden.
1996, als die Waffe gefunden wurde,
ging wahrscheinlich ein Riesenschrei
durch die Schweiz -
im positiven Sinn.
Wir hatten neue Ansatzpunkte,
konnten wieder etwas machen.
Jetzt holen wir ihn.
Die Waffe gehörte einem Mann
namens Carl Doser,
der scheinbar keine Verbindung
zur Familie Siegrist hatte.
Sofort wurde international
nach ihm gesucht.
Die Waffe
war zusammen mit Dosers Pass
in der Wohnung von Dosers Mutter
gefunden worden.
Augenfällig: Seit 1977,
also ein Jahr nach den Morden,
fehlte von Carl Doser jede Spur.
Der Täter ist nicht mehr hier,
er ist weg.
Man fand heraus, dass er weg ist.
Aber wo, fand man nie heraus.
Es ist zumindest sehr auffällig,
dass der Besitzer der Tatwaffe
verschwunden ist.
Ich denke,
das ist ein Schuldgeständnis.
Warum sollte er sonst
verschwunden sein?
Brisant:
Kurz nach der Tat hatte die Polizei
Winchester-Besitzer Carl Doser
aufgesucht und befragt:
Später wurde bekannt,
welch grosse Peinlichkeit
sich die Kriminalpolizei Solothurn
geleistet hat.
Die haben Herrn Doser
1977 zweimal verhört,
als sie diese ca. 2'000-3'000
Winchester-Gewehrbesitzer prüften.
Herr Doser
sagte gegenüber der Kripo,
er habe die Waffe
auf dem Flohmarkt verkauft.
Und mit dieser dünnen Ausrede gab
sich die Kriminalpolizei zufrieden.
Im Nachhinein fragt man sich schon,
ob man damals nicht
genauer hätte hinschauen müssen.
Mit dem Wissen, das wir heute haben,
war das wahrscheinlich ein Fehler.
Wir hatten keine Anhaltspunkte.
Wenn wir nur eine Verbindung gehabt
hätten von Carl Doser zu den Opfern,
irgendeinen Hinweis,
dann hätten wir genauer hingeschaut.
Dann hätten die Basler Kollegen
auch was in den Händen gehabt.
Aber da war gar nichts.
Und doch fragt sich,
weshalb es Doser so leicht gelang,
zu verschwinden,
ohne dass dies auffiel.
Wieso konnte oder wollte niemand
Angaben zu seinem Aufenthalt machen?
Die Zusammenarbeit
der verschiedenen Kantonspolizeien
hat sich verbessert.
Es wird besser kommuniziert, auch
dank der neuen Kommunikationsmittel.
Aber man fragt sich,
ob die Informationen
nicht noch besser fliessen könnten.
Oft wissen die in Zürich nicht,
was die im Wallis machen,
dass es dort vielleicht
einen ähnlichen Fall gab.
Es gibt Verbesserungen, aber man ist
noch nicht dort, wo man sein sollte.
Nicht alle Kantone
sind gleich am Austausch beteiligt.
Es gibt immer noch Hürden in der
Information zwischen den Kantonen,
die nicht so leicht
zu überwinden sind.
Es wäre Potenzial da,
diese Zusammenarbeit zu verbessern.
Max Jäggi hat sein Ziel, den Mörder
von Seewen zu fassen, nicht erreicht.
Auch, weil niemand,
der die Wahrheit kennt, aussagte.
Inzwischen ist der Fall verjährt.
Dass Carl Doser an der Tat beteiligt
war, daran zweifelt Jäggi aber nicht.
Was, wenn heute die Tür aufginge
und Doser hereinkäme?
Wenn er hereinkäme
und ein Bier bestellen würde?
"Guten Tag, Herr Doser.
Wie geht es?"
Vielleicht hat er
überhaupt kein Gewissen.
Vielleicht denkt er,
er habe das Richtige gemacht,
aus seiner Sicht.
Dann sind wir wieder beim Motiv.
Es würde mich schon interessieren,
das ist klar.
Und was, wenn alles ganz anders war?
Was, wenn die Gerüchte stimmen,
dass zur Tatzeit
ein kleinwüchsiger Mann
am Tatort gesehen worden sein soll?
Was, wenn die Verbindungen
der erschossenen Anna Westhäuser
zu den Nazis tatsächlich im
Zusammenhang zum Fünffachmord stehen?
Was, wenn der verschwundene Doser
nicht mit einem persönlichen Motiv,
sondern im Auftrag getötet hatte?
Und er danach nicht freiwillig floh,
sondern zum Verschwinden
gebracht wurde?
Gibt es irgendwo noch jemanden, der
fast ein halbes Jahrhundert später
die Antwort auf diese Fragen kennt?
* Melancholische Klaviermusik *
Wer weiss, was wirklich geschah?
Diese Frage stellt sich auch
die Kantonspolizei Schwyz
seit dem 27. Februar 2004.
Am helllichten Tag
wird in Altendorf am Zürichsee
die 22-jährige Patricia Wilhelm
an ihrem Arbeitsplatz
in einem Reisebüro erschossen.
Die junge Frau aus Einsiedeln wollte
nach Feierabend ihren Vater treffen.
Es lag ihr etwas auf dem Herzen.
Was das war,
konnte sie ihm nie erzählen.
An diesem Tag im Februar
hat ein unbekannter Täter
diese junge Frau
aus dem Leben gerissen
und bei ihrer Familie
unsägliches Leid hinterlassen.
In diesem Film darüber sprechen,
möchte die Familie nicht.
Doch was genau
ist damals Ende Februar geschehen?
Am Tatort in Altendorf
versucht die Polizei
dem Täter oder der Täterin
auf die Spur zu kommen.
Sie findet zwei Patronenhülsen
und zwei männliche DNA-Spuren.
Es fehlen eine Geldkassette
mit mehreren Hundert Franken,
Wilhelms Portemonnaie
und ihre Agenda.
Und v.a. fehlen Zeugen.
Zwischen 15.45 und 16.15 Uhr wurde
an der vielbefahrenden Hauptstrasse
zweimal
auf Patricia Wilhelm geschossen.
Und niemand will
etwas gesehen oder gehört haben.
Es geschah in einem Mehrfamilienhaus
im Erdgeschoss.
In der oberen Wohnung
war niemand da.
Die Kantonsstrasse
ist gleich nebenan, es ist laut.
Wir erhielten keine Meldungen,
dass jemand die Schüsse gehört hat.
Die Schüsse sind in den
Umgebungsgeräuschen untergegangen.
Stephan Grieder,
der damals 40-jährige Chef
der Kriminalpolizei Schwyz,
erinnert sich noch genau.
Ich erinnere mich gut,
wie ich zum ersten Mal ins Tatobjekt
ging und Patricia Wilhelm
im Backoffice auf dem Rücken liegend
vorgefunden habe.
Speziell in Erinnerung geblieben
sind mir ihre Haare,
sie waren fast wie drapiert.
Es sah aus wie ein Heiligenschein.
Benno Kälin war damals
als Reporter von TeleZüri vor Ort.
Es war ähnlich wie heute:
nasskalte Temperaturen.
Es war bereits dunkel,
als ich ankam.
Durch die Dunkelheit sah man gut,
wie die Spurensicherung arbeitete.
Anhand der Art und Weise,
wie sie vorgingen,
und der weissen Kleider
war schnell klar,
dass hier
etwas Schlimmes passiert ist.
Patricia Wilhelm
war allseits beliebt.
Ihre ehemalige Vorgesetzte
Doreen Caflisch
beschrieb sie
als nette, integre Person.
Sie war eine aufgeschlossene,
freundliche, liebenswürdige,
tüchtige, junge Frau.
Diese Tat ist für uns
überhaupt nicht erklärbar.
Am ehesten wahrscheinlich ein Raub.
Geld, ich kann mir eigentlich
nur das vorstellen.
* Spannungsgeladene Musik *
Diese Raubmordthese
war für mich nicht plausibel.
Erst recht nicht, als ich im Verlauf
der weiteren Recherche
von einer sehr zuverlässigen Quelle
erfuhr,
dass die Frau mit zwei
gezielten Schüssen in die Herzgegend
umgebracht worden ist.
Das spricht eher
für eine Exekutierung
als für einen Raubmord.
Der Bargeldbestand ist im Vergleich
mit einer Postfiliale oder Bank
in einem Reisebüro relativ klein.
Das macht es relativ
unwahrscheinlich,
dass es ein Raubmord war.
Für ein Beziehungsdelikt spricht,
dass die meisten Tötungsdelikte
Beziehungsdelikte sind.
Wichtig ist hier, dass man Beziehung
nicht zu eng versteht.
Ein Beispiel:
Falls jemand als Zeuge etwas sieht,
was er nicht sehen sollte,
z.B. Betäubungsmittelhandel
oder ein anderes Verbrechen,
reicht das für eine Beziehung
im Tötungsdelikt.
Durch das Beobachten ist das Opfer
in eine Beziehung getreten,
was als Ausgangsbasis
für ein Tötungsdelikt reicht.
Die Ermittler gehen davon aus,
dass ein Beziehungsdelikt
am wahrscheinlichsten ist.
Die zwei am Tatort gefunden
Patronenhülsen sind auffällig.
Eine stammt aus dem Jahr 52
aus der ehemaligen Tschechoslowakei
und die andere aus dem Jahr 56
und war im Militär in Ex-Jugoslawien
verbreitet.
Das Spezielle an dieser Tat war,
dass eine sehr alte Waffe
und alte Munition verwendet wurden.
Bei der Tatwaffenbestimmung
haben wir herausgefunden,
dass es eine Waffe aus
der ehemaligen Tschechoslowakei war.
Eine CZ 52, Kaliber 7,62 mm,
ein Selbstlader
oder eine ähnliche Waffe,
die ähnliche Verfeuerungsspuren
hinterlässt.
Auf den ersten Blick
war es eine aussergewöhnliche Waffe.
Damals gab es
ein anderes Waffengesetz.
Im Verlauf der Ermittlungen
ergab sich,
dass diese Waffe
in den Ostblockstaaten
relativ weit verbreitet war,
v.a. in Offizierskreisen.
Durch die damalige,
ziemlich andere Waffengesetzgebung
konnte Waffenimport
einfacher stattfinden.
Z.B. kamen im Jugoslawienkrieg in
den 1990er-Jahren viele Waffen rein.
Deshalb war diese Waffe gar nicht
so selten, wie wir gedacht haben.
Wir haben das auch regelmässig
europaweit abgeglichen,
aber das Pendant der Tatwaffe
wurde nie gefunden.
Die Ermittler untersuchen parallel
zur Tatwaffensuche
auch die gesicherte DNA des Tatorts.
Mehr als Tausend Alibis
wurden überprüft.
Hundert Männer mussten ihre DNA
abgleichen lassen.
Wenn man eine DNA-Spur hat,
aber keine Übereinstimmung
in der Datenbank,
beginnt man im engeren Beziehungs-
kreis des Opfers zu ermitteln,
also hier von Patricia Wilhelm.
In welcher Beziehung
standen die Personen,
gibt es ein mögliches Motiv usw.?
Dann wird auch DNA abgenommen
und verglichen.
Aber alle Ermittlungen,
auch im engsten Beziehungskreis
von Patricia Wilhelm,
führten über die DNA-Spuren
zu keinem Ermittlungserfolg.
Der Fall bleibt undurchsichtig.
Niemand will
etwas gesehen oder gehört haben.
Die Polizei
stösst auf Mauern des Nichtwissens,
vielleicht auch des Schweigens.
Drei Verdächtige werden verhaftet -
müssen aber mangels Beweisen
wieder freigelassen werden.
Niemand konnte sich
einen Reim darauf machen,
warum diese Frau umgebracht wurde.
Nicht im Ansatz war bei jemandem
ein Motiv erkennbar.
Aufgrund dessen dachte ich, dass es
ein schwieriger Fall sein musste.
Ich habe schon viele Kriminalfälle
recherchiert.
Im Normalfall kommt man bei
der Umfeldrecherche schnell weiter.
Man hört Gerüchte.
Hier hörte man nicht mal Gerüchte.
Bei einem Gerücht
stellt sich meistens heraus,
dass es eine gute Hypothese war.
Hier gab es gar nichts
in diese Richtung.
Doch weil der Wirklichkeit mit Logik
allein nur z.T. beizukommen ist,
gingen die Ermittler
auch unkonventionelle Wege.
Wir haben auch Hypnose angewendet,
auch bei Auskunftspersonen,
falls sie irgendwas gesehen haben,
das im Unterbewusstsein
gespeichert ist.
Wir sind jedem Hinweis nachgegangen,
auch wenn er von einem Medium kam,
z.B. über Wünschelruten.
Wir haben Bachbetten durchsucht,
tauchten in Seen
und haben nichts ausgeschlossen.
Schliesslich haben wir sogar
ein Medium zugezogen.
Dieses behauptete,
es kann mit Toten reden.
Auch das machten wir.
Wir waren sehr überrascht,
was das Medium sagen konnte.
Es hatte Wissen zum Sachverhalt,
das für uns überraschend war.
Wir fragten uns,
woher diese Person das wisse.
Aber auch mit diesem Medium, das
angeblich mit Toten reden konnte,
erwuchs kein Ermittlungsansatz,
der zum Erfolg führte.
Eine Belohnung von 5'000 Fr.
wurde für sachdienliche Hinweise
ausgesetzt.
Ohne Ergebnis.
Die ratlosen Ermittler versuchten es
2019 mit einem weiteren Effort:
In der deutschen Sendung
"Aktenzeichen XY"
wandten sie sich
an die breite Öffentlichkeit.
Der Beweggrund war,
dass wir mit unseren
Ermittlungsmethoden am Ende waren.
Wir wussten nicht mehr weiter.
Dienstag, der 24. Februar 2004:
Patricia Wilhelm
arbeitet seit knapp vier Wochen
im Reisebüro in Altendorf.
An diesem Abend führt sie ein langes
Gespräch mit ihrer Freundin Monika,
die einen mehrmonatigen Urlaub
in Australien verbringt.
Ja. Jetzt bin ich in einem Hostel.
Ich, ähm ...
* Tür *
Hallo Schatz.
- Hi.
Dort floss ein grosser Teil
unserer Bemühungen rein.
Wir hofften,
ein mögliches Motiv zu erhalten.
So hätten wir die Ermittlungen
fokussieren können,
vielleicht auf eine konkrete Person.
Aber leider haben wir diese
Information nicht herausgefunden.
Auch nach 19 Jahren ist der Fall
Patricia Wilhelm nicht abgeschlossen.
Die Kantonspolizei Schwyz
geht immer noch jedem Hinweis nach.
Noch immer hofft sie, dass
irgendjemand das Schweigen bricht.
Das Gefühl, man habe die Arbeit
nicht gemacht, verfolgt einen.
Man habe etwas übersehen,
aber man weiss nicht was.
Wenn man einen Fehler macht
und weiss, wo er ist,
kann man damit anders umgehen,
als wenn man nicht weiss,
ob man etwas übersehen hat.
Mord verjährt in der Schweiz
erst nach 30 Jahren.
Rechtlich
besteht die Möglichkeit noch,
jemanden zu überführen.
Ich schliesse es nicht aus,
dass jemand erwischt werden kann.
Es ist zwar unwahrscheinlich
nach so langer Zeit.
Die Zeit spielt gegen die Polizei.
Je länger es dauert,
desto unwahrscheinlicher
wird ein Fall geklärt.
Gleichzeitig gibt es eine DNA-Spur,
die man nicht zuordnen kann.
Falls der Täter
noch einmal ein Delikt begeht
und wieder eine Spur hinterlässt,
gibt es einen neuen Ansatzpunkt.
Oder er wird erwischt und man
bemerkt die Übereinstimmung der DNA.
Jemand,
der ein solches Delikt begeht,
geht wahrscheinlich nicht deliktfrei
durch das weitere Leben.
Das ist wahrscheinlich jemand,
der auch sonst kriminell war.
Dann gibt es noch die Möglichkeit,
dass irgendjemanden etwas weiss,
es aber aus verschiedenen Gründen
nicht gesagt hat.
Vielleicht eine ehemalige Partnerin,
die doch noch zur Polizei geht,
um ihr Gewissen zu bereinigen.
Es ist nicht sehr wahrscheinlich,
aber es ist möglich,
dass das Delikt
noch geklärt werden kann.
Es sei ein Verbrecher,
wer die Wahrheit kennt
und sie nicht ausspricht.
Jeder Ermittler dieser Welt
wird dieses Zitat bestätigen.
Das Schweigen bleibt der stille Feind
der Wahrheit.
SWISS TXT / Accessibility Services
M. Gassner, N. Oeggerli - 2023